ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show we are
uh i believe in the death rows here of
the trump administration the aides are
coming in and telling him it's time
to let it go i believe he's got his
family now he's got ivanka he's got
jared
he's got uh his sons don jr and eric
he's got uh rudy giuliani
and it's a small group in the uh in the
in the camp of don't concede
and then i think most people now are
starting to say
hey i don't know
i don't know what you do if you're him i
don't know i think you
you leave probably and go and do
something else
i don't you know i don't know why you're
doing this into the first place
can't get anything done the deep state
and everyone else is against it's like
what
what is the point like truly what is the
point like
if it's hopelessly corrupt which i might
even agree with him on like if
if he sat down and had lunch with me
after this and went the whole thing's
[ __ ] i'd go back
i would agree with you why even do it
for the rallies right
for the fun i mean just to be
springsteen
to get out on a stage and like rock out
like if you
you know i i get it the guy believes
that he can do something you can't
i mean it's clear that you cannot i
don't know
i mean i don't want to be too negative
but
even by his own admission the swamp
uh his words is
just you know too great
to be drained maybe maybe it's time to
go
i don't know anything about voting or
voting irregularities
i've spoken to a lot of people that go
this
isn't happening people at fox news
republicans people that wanted them to
win people that have a lot of [ __ ]
money and wanted the guy to win
and they're like there's no real
evidence of these these massive voting
irregularities a lot of them are like
troll
things where they're like this guy who's
000 years old voted in wisconsin and
then you look it up you're like that's
not true and i'm sure every election
there are some voting irregularities it
means like how many of them are there
how big of a problem is it um
recount do whatever you need to do
recount it
make everybody happy
you know again i don't know i don't
these vote counting operations
i don't know what's going on there trump
has
filed a lot of lawsuits i don't know the
merit that they have or not
i think he probably lost i i i feel like
that i don't know if they if they stole
the election from him
unless you want to say that all the mail
and ballots are invalid
and uh which i don't think you can do
i think it makes sense to say that the
people that took covert very seriously
probably voted for biden and that
trump won in the day of voting but in
the mail-in ballots
they are going to heavily break for
biden because those are people
that probably for the reason of covid
didn't want to vote so
i don't is there a tremendous group of
people that's like
i'm not voting because of covid
i'm but i'm voting for trump probably
not
there's probably not a huge contingent
of people that are like
i'm afraid of coven and
so much that i won't walk into a voting
place and i
love trump that's
logically i just go that's probably not
a huge group
well i don't put anything past anybody i
don't know
but i think it's getting to the point
now where even like trump's
close advisors are going hey
what are we gonna do here what's the
plan
i think he could use this opportunity to
give one of the most
scathing uh
concession speeches in american
political history the most
scathing and entertaining don't even
mention
biden by name don't even mention kamala
by name
kamala rogan kept correcting me kamala
don't mention them my name just do a
scathing
concession speech don't even concede but
you got to leave
but don't even concede god i i won
how about this resign so that pence can
pardon you
for whatever they try to go at you for
when you leave
i'm not trying to be a naysayer i know a
lot of people are angry with me they're
like no
he's gotta fight on for what
it's over and guess what
the aoc who i called the genocidal
maniac on twitter today and i stand by
that
she's done too her she's
done the the right
of the the young right wingers and the
young
left where they're all done
corporate power won
they won and you are now you're going to
go from
zoomer to boomer the zoomer to boomer
pipeline
and this is what's gonna within a year
you're gonna forget that you ever
believed in anything within a year
within three years you're gonna have a
shitty job
a girlfriend a boyfriend you're gonna
start
liking the entertainment that comes out
and you're gonna start
pricing out cruises because coronavirus
is gonna be over and you're gonna go i
wanna go on a cruise
you're gonna start eating it you're
gonna move to a shitty suburb
and you're gonna start going out to eat
at a local restaurant
and that and it's over now and aoc
could tweet all she wants about let's
put all the names of people that never
said anything positive about trump
look at this lunatic is anyone archiving
these trump sycophants for when they try
to downplay or deny
their complicity in the future i foresee
decent probability of many deleted
tweets writings photos
uh in the future um
this woman has the same impulses as
donald trump
impulses she wants to start making lists
of people that supported trump i mean
that's a problem no
but really trump
got a higher percentage of the
african-american vote and latino vote
young people did not come out again as
they never do
the socialist coalition just it didn't
work
didn't work you've got joe biden kamala
harris you've got two republicans
essentially
in the white house so the extremes
on both sides ended up losing
it's business as usual
who told you that who told you that
sorry i hate being right
i'm right week in week out
all the time and i tell you people
things and you get
mad at me for being correct
what an odd thing to be mad at a person
for being
on the money all the time here's what's
gonna happen
no what
and then it happens and they're still
angry with me
it's back to business as usual
don't worry about it we've only got a
few more years left on earth
enjoy it it'll be fine go
back to i predict what's going to happen
this is what i predict i could be wrong
but i'm never wrong
i predict when covet ends
when trump is out we are going to enter
another era of
goofy silly
comedy and entertainment i believe that
we are heading towards a great era
potentially
of people like jim carrey people like
eddie murphy
people that are not
focused on the political
the social commentary to a degree you'll
have those people
that are funny that are in in that space
but i think you're going to see a return
to goofy and thank
god for that i hope it's my hope
it's my hope imagine if people got more
serious
after this i don't think so imagine that
could it happen colbert is crying all
the late night hosts cry
every week i mean what else could they
do throw tantrums
i guess they could lay on the floor and
pound their fists like a child
but i mean they cry every week you know
it's a regular occurrence now
to see late night comedians crying how
could that get more serious i
imagine uh they're gonna get goofy again
here he comes i mean look at
look at this person what is he wearing
he looks like a vegas lounge singer he's
in all black what is he doing
i don't know he makes tens of millions
of dollars a year
and he's dressed like a divorced history
teacher
who's going out on the first date he's
had in six months
christ so we all knew he would do this
this is late night comedy
i mean
what i didn't know is that it would hurt
so much yeah
these are comedians i didn't expect this
to break my heart these are comedians in
twenty twenty that's a good thing for me
to cast a dark shadow on our most sacred
right
from the briefing room in the white
house our house not his
that is devastating this
this is heartbreaking for the same
reason that
i didn't want him to get coveted
certainly why i wanted him to survive
because he is the president of the
united
states that office means something and
that office should have some
shred of decency
okay well those are comedians so
uh that's the comedy that you've been
provided with for the last four years
maybe that will change like perhaps
this will be the catalyst in the
business that i'm in because
occasionally i do mention that
uh not all the time because i don't
think everything's about comedy and i
don't think that like
the kind of comedy you get justifies
whatever happening
if you love trump i get it this is not a
good consolation prize
that these people stop crying i'm just
saying
an unintended consequence might be
that there might be uh you know
some silly comedy
coming back you know nothing
too serious i don't know if that's the
case or not
everyone is so serious now
i went out to dinner tonight
in a parking lot surrounded by
traffic cones thanks gavin newsom
because we can't
walk in a building unless we promise to
burn it down blm
so we have to sit in a parking lot
surrounded by traffic cones to have
dinner
and and this we're we're in echo park
los angeles
which is a nightmare it's uh a
rapidly decaying hellscape and it's full
of these
artists and pseudo-intellectuals but
primarily dilettantes
people that think they're in the arts
and are not people are under the
impression they are comedians and are
not uh and then of course you get a
a few comedians here and there uh we're
sitting in
an and this restaurant called tex which
is a horrible name but it's a good
restaurant it's
it's country french as the waitress uh
told us she has not showered in weeks
and she has her ratty hair
uh clinging to her face uh in
amphetamine sweat and she said
it's country french cuisine she is
correct about that
and the food is very good the food is
very good but
text tax what's it called tests
folks it's gone anyway it
yeah t-a-i-x french restaurant and it's
really good
it's been there since 1927. well what's
coming in
a high-rise in echo park because
more uh people need to live in condos
in ecco park so they have a high rise
coming in and this restaurant is closing
we all know that we all know that
and instead of just enjoying one of our
last meals of course we have the
waitress
who we have to relive her uh
horror for the entirety of the meal
she's telling us about the owner and if
the owner's not really doing anything
and the owner doesn't let them know
what's going on and they don't know when
they're closing and they
he didn't you know she goes well
we had to set this whole thing up we had
to get the tables and chairs from the
downstairs
and then she's talking about the
councilwoman i hope uh
nithya wins because some some socialist
candidates she goes i hope nythia wins
you know she's taking deep breaths and
and i want to grab her and say
with all due respect can you shut your
mouth please we are trying to enjoy a
meal
can you shut your mouth every time she
came near the table
i mean she looked wounded i'm like do we
have to take you to a hospital
i know it's been a tough five months i
know you haven't worked
can you pull it together for christ
i can't deal with it shut up about the
city councilwoman
who you think is gonna save your life i
hope she win
i hope she wins this gaunt heroin addict
at the french restaurant and this is all
the servers now
all of the shirt because now it's the
fall and i'm doing a lot of you know
one of my sports which i go out to
dinner now and this is kind of my sport
we kind of settle into the from now
until january this is going out to
dinner season you see people
you haven't seen in a while and now
because i live in los angeles
you get to go out to dinner and parking
lots and alleys and things like that and
it's great
but the servers now are like
they're they have this weird like
they're
wearing their heart on their sleeve
because they've been out of work for so
long and everything's been so
tragic for so long and they
feel like you have to sit there
and like take it you have to like
stomach
their nightmare of a life while you try
to eat
you know risotto and you have to sit
there and go
yes the owners doesn't he doesn't even
tell you when it's closing huh
what do you want from us you want to
come live with us is that what you
envision happens at the end of this
i go well why don't you live with us
this seems fair
don't tell me that you hope a certain
politician
won during dinner who cares
leave it alone it's potentially a
volatile
conversation because i hope i hope she
won
i hope she won i'm sleeping in this lot
god i'm trying to eat food
that's a little expensive and i don't
want to feel guilty about it
so can you get out of here i mean the
woman
had the look of somebody who like chases
down semen with cough syrup under a
bridge
without like the spunky fun-loving
personality you'd imagine someone like
that having
i don't want a super serious in the
midst of a crisis
server put it together i just did a big
election livestream with rogan i was
tired
the airbnb canceled on us i didn't get
any sleep the night before
i got an argument with dan the kid that
opens for me and i we i made him
go sit under a tree i'm like i don't
want to look at you i we can't even be
in the same parking lot
we get to rogan's early nobody's there
we got to sit on the curb
because the airbnb couldn't get a
cleaning crew in the day is a nightmare
you know what i did i went to work i
shut my mouth and went to work
and we had a great time i didn't
uh make everybody uh you know is
participate in in my misfortune
it's not fair keep it
close to the vest and
here's another thing i got to be very
honest with you
and i know this isn't popular enough
with the donating to the kids in the
hospital with cancer
no one believes that the money's going
to them and it's the same kid over and
over again
you're not fooling me it's the same bald
kid over and over again
i can you tell them apart it's to say
why am i going to the fat store and
don't
everyone in the fat store is dying why
are there more dead people when i check
out
can it can you explain to me why i gotta
look at this cancerous
child who looks pretty [ __ ] skinny by
the way
all the fat people when they check out
of the fat store
have to look at these emaciated children
we're jealous as [ __ ]
we're not donating money we want to know
how they look like that
how do they see their rib cage
and i gotta look at emaciated cancer
kids to make me
feel like [ __ ] and then you gotta ask me
for a dollar
to help these skinny [ __ ] i think not
let me out of the fat store and just let
me go
and the other thing dxl you pieces of
[ __ ]
stop giving the paper 25
reward get rid of the rewards at the fat
store
number one get rid of them
we shouldn't even have the fat rewards
at dxl you shouldn't say
hey you're fat again this month here's
25 come back here next month if you
don't have a coronary
and and get 25 off 190
shirt because apparently it's four times
the price of anything else
because you're fat so they give you this
little piece of thing and you lose it
they don't give you any digital rewards
you lose and they go bring it back next
month they give you and i
yell at them now i go this is [ __ ] i
get right in their face
i go you know i'm gonna lose it you say
i'm gonna bring it in next month i said
no
i scream and i might say none of the fat
[ __ ]
who shop here are gonna remember this
little piece of paper
and we're gonna eat it so do it
digitally or don't do it at all
email us or don't do it at all and
enough with the saint jude's hospital
hey donate to these skinny fox no thanks
that's just a psa for the fat store
which i'm trying very hard to not have
to go to anymore
because i've only have shopped there for
the last three years
and it is very depressing that store
and the people that work there are very
diverse every now and then it's nice to
see someone who's
much fatter than me there you will see
someone who's like 500 pounds
and that makes you feel great
that makes you feel great when somebody
just waddles in
and that's great you feel hot
you start looking at yourself like i'm
hot as [ __ ]
when this fat knee walks in and the
guy's
knees are just buckling and he's just
like
and he can barely speak he can just kind
of motion with his arm and his arms not
even an arm anymore it's just like a
of just a wing it's like a wing of fat
and they just and he's always with some
like handler nurse or whatever
and they're just trying to like wrap a
coat around them i feel hot as [ __ ] i
jerk off the dressing room like yeah
that's right but enough
but we're back we had a nice dinner at
this place i'm not [ __ ] on this
restaurant i like the restaurant
and i like the restaurant i just i would
just request that the waitress
shut her mouth also don't tell me you've
been working here
i'm trillion years that depresses all of
us it's just depressing to all
it depresses all of us when you tell us
you've been there 12 years
that's depresses everybody that's not
something where we're supposed to
congratulate you
i've been here 12 years ago
good
okay good
you're all smoking and you gotta stop
and you gotta stop
the vaping and the e-cigarettes cause
it's just as bad people
are dying left and right well you got it
and they're almost not cool anymore you
feel that they've gotten to the point
where they're not cool now
they were cool for a little bit now
they're not cool and
what you got to do is get lucy it's a
lozenge with four milligrams of nicotine
in cherry ice flavor or wintergreen or
cinnamon
or pomegranate okay it's 20 20. get rid
of the six unplug your vape
throw out your dip and get some lucy
nicotine gum or lozenges
a lot of my audience loves donald trump
and they feel bad that he's not the
president
and many of them are going to smoke a
lot of bots a lot of ciggies
among other things but what they should
do is switch to lucy nicotine
lozenge it's founded by caltech
scientists and former smokers
looking for a better and cleaner
nicotine alternative
finally tobacco alternatives that don't
suck
if you go to lucy.co and use promo code
tim at checkout you're gonna be very
happy that's lucy.co
promo code tim at checkout warning this
product contains nicotine derived from
tobacco
nicotine is an addictive chemical
however this is a great way to step down
off of the amount of nicotine you get
from six
very important i'm telling you right now
folks this is it
you understand me this is your time to
change your life you're gonna do it
it's 20 20 you say [ __ ] it i'm not a
smoker anymore
i'm not smoking i am
going to do something else i can see it
i can see the future i'm looking at
myself and i'm
not a smoker i'm standing on a rock and
i've just killed someone but i am
not smoking i am looking at the body on
the beach
that is contorted you know i'm
trying to imagine how it all happened
because i feel like i blacked out and i
did black out
but the rage just came from the you know
from my
depth and then it just kind of came out
of my hands and then i pushed this
person
off a bluff off a cliff and they are
dead now
but you know what the last thing on my
mind is lighting a cigarette
as i stare at their dead body and i
think about how much
the dna or you know evidence that people
are going to have
fibers from my code or whatever i'm not
thinking about someone can see i'm
thinking about
dissolving the body in a tub of lye acid
i am thinking about that i'm thinking
about how long it would take me to
to weight the body down so that it could
could uh sink i'm thinking about that
i'm thinking about what is prison like
like if i just
walked away and end up in prison what's
that like
you know i'm thinking about all these
things but the last thing on my mind
is a cigarette because i've taken a lucy
nicotine lozenge
lucy.co promo code tim at checkout i'm
telling you change your life a lot of
people in my audience smoke
you shouldn't also
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco nicotine is an
addictive chemical lucy dot
co promo code tim no days wasted
i'll tell you right now you will not
waste a single day you like to go out
there and get
boozed up let's get real you want to go
out there and get boozed up everybody's
doing that you know
no days wasted is here to help you
maximize life's moments it's a dhm detox
it's a vitamin for people
who like to enjoy their drinks tens of
thousands of people are
using dhm detox as their drinking body
enjoy your drinks and forget the sunday
scaries and feeling like garbage just
take two capsules after your first
couple of drinks and it goes to work
dhm detox uses science to help boost
your body's natural response how about
that it helps break down the toxins in
alcohol
they're easy to share with friends and
family also they've just launched their
new hydration replenisher with immune
support
these are really really good you know if
you need
to function and have brain power and
have clarity
and want to be part of the workforce or
part of
your marriage or part of being a dad or
a mom
or a nephew or an aunt or a baby if
you're a baby and you're hammered
you take one of these you can go back to
being a baby and not be like a waste of
life you could be like
um i mean it's so important
it's so important also if you're gonna
if you're gonna get someone really drunk
but you want them to work the next day
so if you're really gonna like get
somebody really hammered but you want
them to work the next day
slip em this yeah you know
i'm not saying why you would do that i'm
not
probably not a good idea to get anyone
drunk but i'm saying sometimes you want
someone drunk like hey this guy's fun
when he's hammered and then the next day
we need him uh you know
with a wheelbarrow just out there doing
his job
this will make sure that you do not feel
wasted the next day it's a great way to
support our show
i've got you 20 off your first order and
free shipping in the us
just head over to no days wasted dot co
slash tim no days wasted dot co slash
tim
and use promo code tim at checkout
that's no days wasted dot co c-o-t-i-m
i had fun taping a youtube thing today
with cody co
youtuber very funny nice guy
like a genuinely nice person very nice a
good guy
pretty girlfriend surfs like you know
just a person that uh
you know uh has no reason to not be a
good person
you know what i mean and uh we went and
tried uh
milkshakes at slushy land
okay i'm not really a huge milkshake guy
but he goes would you like to do a
dessert
and of course you know because this show
is called sweet tooth and i said like
yeah i'd like to do like a chocolate
souffle but i mean it's la
so what do you these people don't know
what a chocolate souffle is right right
so we went to slushy land
you know it was fine it's fun
go support slushyland by the way if
you're in the valley i don't i'm not
i'm not [ __ ] on slushy land i you
know
it was good it's the cereal ice cream
thing that everybody's doing now i don't
know what
i don't know what that is i don't
understand
what what the obsession is with cereal
other than magic spoon which is
essential but i don't understand why
everybody now cannot
everybody has to everybody's trying to
recapture their childhood
everything is a you know nostalgia based
activity
and uh the at uh slushy land they do a
lot of cereal and we had these weird
shaved ice corn things
interesting it was odd
it was odd did you like the corn shaved
ice i did not
i didn't really enjoy it either i spit
it out too
but that's okay what are you gonna do
ben spits it out if the block goes i
hope they didn't see
hope they didn't see me spitting it out
i'm like thanks a lot
making me look bad
trying to do a little party for
friendsgiving i used to hate
friendsgivings and
i still kind of do because i hate other
people
and i don't like them near me but i do
want to do a little one in which we're
trying to put together a
friend's giving i always i didn't like
the connotation of friendsgiving i
always thought it was kind of like
i especially in new york city because to
me new york city of friendsgiving should
be like
two uh transgender people or gay people
who had been kicked out of their house
in the midwest
who can't go home for thanksgiving who
do cocaine together in the east village
bar
that's what friends giving should be it
should not be like a cluster of young
professionals
drinking cold brew and talking about
corporate music festivals which is
really
what it is and that disgusts me but new
york city the city i love is dead
and i don't care about it anymore and i
don't care about
whatever whatever hell they want to
create over there they can do it
um but yeah so that's why the friends
giving i
don't like like the young professional
thing
is not for me like it's this confident
like paint by numbers life where people
are like
i want to do what everybody else has
done and i want to get
what they've gotten and i want to i want
to check
every box and i want to go to this
school and major in this
and do this and do that it's just never
been for me i i don't i don't look down
on the people
who live like that i understand why a
lot of people have to live like that
but that's my aversion to friends giving
i don't like these
these created uh things right i don't
i don't like i don't like corporate
music festivals i never liked that
because it all
it felt you know everybody was uh
corralled
into uh governor's island or whatever
and they're like and here's the 12 acts
and here's what you see
and and and to me i i just i want to go
out in the world and find things and
enjoy and i want to
i want my music to be people that are
broken down and it's
almost over and they're performing in a
bar in austin texas
and they're bleeding as they sing
they're bleeding
their hands are bleeding and they're
barely making sense anymore
and they're just they're they're really
just saying one sentence over and over
they're going
we're all gonna die tomorrow we're all
gonna die
today and everybody there watching them
is kind of transfixed
by this and you know they don't have any
success and they
want to die and that's the type of music
i
like i don't really i like all kinds of
music i just i gravitate
i'm of course kidding a little but like
guys like james mcmurtry where i can go
and see them
in the continental club at midnight on
wednesday in austin texas
and he's [ __ ] great and he murders
and he's great
you know phenomenal and and i went with
your friend travis and we saw that show
and it was great
and there was nothing about it that was
like
thought up and abort this is very
different than the corporate steakhouse
which i
adore but when it comes to music i like
it to be a little
rough around the edges when i see music
and i know that there's big acts and
i've seen
springsteen and tina turner all these
massive planets i get it
but like the the corporate music
festival
i also sobered up before all of this
fun stuff right i sobered up before it
was
fun before they really started
designing activities for people to just
do drugs i used to have to do drugs
and go about my regular day i this
wasn't a theme park
of drugs when i was you know
really using yeah there was lollapalooza
there was things like that but now i
mean they just
literally create events for young
professionals to go and do
molly or whatever they're doing and you
know have fun
i just missed out on that you know i had
to sit there
i had to do cocaine in an office
okay with sweaty middle-aged
delusional psychopaths who were losing
everything
and that wasn't exactly the party was it
i had to sit there and do lines of
cocaine
in an office where next to me some fat
slob
was eating a chicken parmesan that he
could barely afford
that was the party isn't it fun
when i look back on my drug use what a
waste
what a waste
i should have been on governor's island
rolling around in the grass
but i was not why
because i was listening to a
presentation
in the huntington hilton
coke to the gills trying to learn
how to sell mortgages
what a waste what a horrible life
what a horror that's why when i go to
dinner i don't need your nightmares
you don't think i have nightmare why
don't you sit down i'll tell you about
my life
yes oh you're upset that the
restaurant's closing
i lived in fear sexuality was always
fear-based i couldn't be honest with
anyone
my mother's is schizophrenic my father's
is a
salesman who like doesn't sell anything
i was a salesman who didn't sell
anything i spent a decade doing cocaine
and instead of [ __ ] on a beach i
sat in an office in long island
what and now i just want to forget that
happened and have a cassoulet
at the french restaurant that's closing
without you
and your pain
attaching yourself to my dinner
we we all don't have problems do you
want me to
my problems every minute of every day
that's what i like about dan dan didn't
have any problems that's why i like
having dan around he doesn't
he doesn't know what problems he's
perplexed this kid grew up in a cult
he grew up in a christian cult they made
him think he was
had no value when he was going to hell
and they were right
he knows the darkness
he knows what it is from texas they
don't speak to each other they all just
stare at the sky
until the end that's all they do they
until a merciful god smites them
and we're just trying to have chocolate
moose
in a parking lot without your horror
is it too much to ask but that's what i
like about dan if dan just doesn't he
doesn't understand
his like biggest problem is that his mom
was mean to him once
that's his issue he'll be like yeah my
mom was a little mean to me
let me tell you right now i wish to god
my mother could have been mean to me she
was at wendy's
collecting toy sets she was collecting
disney toy sets and cataloging them
and putting them under her bed and
during hurricane sandy
they all floated down the street
and princess diana bears finally made
their escape
and floated down the street in long
island and i had to walk through them
getting into the house
yes it would be nice if my mother was
mean to me
but that's why i keep him around because
he lightens me up
this guy darkens me but i need that
we can't do the show with dan dan
doesn't understand any of it
i start screaming and yelling about the
horrors dan goes i don't understand
what about girls in the pool in the frat
i say no to the frat
i say every day i go to the fat store
and i have to look at these skinny
cancer [ __ ] on the way out
makes me feel like [ __ ]
and dana go but they're sick and i go no
i'm sick of it
but that's why it's good to have him
around you need someone around
who has a different life experience than
you who doesn't know what the horrors
are
he doesn't know what the horrors are you
know
he's proud of his dad his dad gets two
bronze stars in iraq
i'd be proud even my father worked at
color tile
he worked at colored tile do you
understand
that's where fat women from long island
come in
and he i think he got fired from that he
couldn't
handle the rigors of color tile
this guy's that has two bronze stars
my father drove a mazda navajo
that's for people that can't afford a
ford explorer
some monsters your dad has two bronze
star
you complain about you don't or you're
not allowed to complain about anything
you're from good people they're pedigree
they're pedigreed peep these are real
people
bronze stars i love my father
but i mean he sells why he's like me
he's full of [ __ ]
but that's why i like to keep dana rats
like you don't make a lot of friends in
life and in my age
of 35 you really don't make any friends
friends are a
problem for the most part that's what
you people need to re
that's the other thing that disgusts me
about young people is like
you need to understand that your friends
are a pro
i love i mean listen i just got made
godfather to a beautiful
baby boy that my friends because now i
have a little money so they made me
godfather let's
get very real about what that is but
that's okay
but i love him he's a beautiful little
baby boy
but i'm now worried about this little
guy you know and i like i
like his parents but i mean you know i
mean
if something happens to them i gotta
raise this little guy you know
and and i i think a lot of the time that
i should kind of raise them
and i'm they're they're good they're
fine i'm just saying that like
your friends become a liability is my
point
they just handed me the kid i'm sitting
there they're like
i don't know what they're doing they
just hand me the kid i'm sitting in my
backyard the dog the bulldogs running
around like
destroying the house the kid's like the
kid's six weeks old he's like
riding the bulldog around the house then
they come hand me the kid and go uh
that's
you're you're the godfather now you're
the godfather and by the way where's
your check
huh and i i appreciate that but your
friends are a liability now
they're a lie they're gonna want things
from you so what's good about dan is
that he's just
he's he's he's he's a little bit of a
brat and he doesn't know how good he's
[ __ ] had it
so every day i tell him i tell him and
he'll get sick of that soon and not be
friends with me anymore
but oh i tell him all the time this is
how good you [ __ ] had it you've got a
great
you've had a great [ __ ] life and
and you don't understand the horrors
that i've been the
nightmares that my life has been
it's it's indescribable my mother
i made her take me to le cirque
you've been and in eighth grade lesser
2000 in the palace hotel and this [ __ ]
wore a sweater with a cat on it and
immediately the maitre d was like oh
good
the trash pigs are here
so i'm gonna walk through the dining
room at le cirque
with my mother with a sweater with a cat
on it
is that not as bad as getting shot by
the cops
out of hoodie on i'm asking i've never
been shot by the cops
i'm asking a question is that not as bad
i think it's
on par i think it's on par
let me go speak to victims of police
violence i believe they will agree with
me
that it is on par to walk into a french
restaurant with your mother
who's wearing like a cat's like a winnie
the pooh sweater
to leserk this goofy [ __ ]
dan's probably the last friend on me
i'll make a few career friends
you can't make too many more i'm 35 i'm
full
with friends the friends that i have now
are starting to become a problem
and they will become more and more of a
problem so i can't
you know i love the little guy i'm going
to be a great godfather i'm going to
give the money
i'm going to watch out for but it's like
i can't god forbid i become friends with
another couple that wants me to be a god
i can't do it
i what am i going to do i mean i guess i
can
but i mean you know this couple usually
most couples you're a godfather you go
yeah i'm the kid will be great this
couple i'm like i'm
probably gonna i might have to step in
here raise again
i might have to raise a kid
i might have to call child protective
services on them
to take the kid i might call a lawyer
and i may get the kid now
to just avoid the embarrassment of later
on
you know i'm kidding of course it's a
comedy
show i miss donald trump already i do
miss
i do miss him i miss him a little bit
he's not gone yet and yet i miss him
but i think his post presidency he's not
going to be like jimmy carter i mean
this guy jimmy carter just goes and
builds houses for the homeless
i mean you want to talk about boring
and by the way and by the way
i don't even i don't even know anymore
like what the homeless answer is i don't
even know what it is
i don't even know what it is homeless
people have become
so like they're they're like we should
utilize that skill set that they have
like
in la they live on like an overpass
while cars just go by them at 90 miles
an hour
there's got to be like that's kind of
impressive
and there's got to be a way to key into
that
like a guy who starts every day
walking across a busy highway in
sandals something's
something's going on there that i think
is positive
but i don't know i don't know how to go
in and
and get it i don't know how to go in and
get it
that's all but i i look at many of the
homeless people around town and i go
and this is probably the wrong feeling i
got to say this delicately i
say everything delicately here you
understand but i
look at some of the homeless people
around town and i go
good for them like they're doing it
they're really doing it and i think
we're not
nearly as positive about homelessness as
we should be
i think we should be more positive like
why don't put up banners that say
you're the la homeless we're doing it
what about a banner that says hey
homeless for another year
you're doing it you're still raising
your kids
they still alive we're doing it
why not
i'm serious because things are so bad
what you mean
why not be a little positive about it
it's
not going away we're not making it
better
so why not like do like a campaign
to make people feel good about being
homeless
like stop shaming them from being
and i like that we're sitting on housed
now so we don't even call them home but
we stay just unhoused
like temporarily how let's move full
force
into a branded campaign
make homelessness cool
what about that what about if it was
what if it was cool to not have a house
think about it remember the 60s you
don't remember it
people like lived in fields they lived
they were in colts they lived in
communes
it was kind of cool they were like [ __ ]
it dude get a house that [ __ ] that's
square i don't want to be a square
why not like have that happen again
make people feel cool for being homeless
why am i not asked how to solve these
things
make it feel look i live i live on a
highway
i don't live in a condo i live on a
[ __ ]
highway there's something
badass about that we need to lean into
it as
a society and as a culture you know
covet has become it is now back
the the cases are uh up if i do a
friend's giving i gotta get
covet tests for everybody if they come
over because i've decided to stay in la
for another year and we have
we got a house for a year and if people
come over
now i have to test them for corona this
is what you have to do now if you have
an event in your house you got to
set up an er in the house for people
you got to set up iv bags you got to
you got to have a full thing so what
what i'm doing is i gotta figure out
like how to get a
doctor or a nurse to
sit outside my home and do covered rapid
covert tests
for everybody that wants to come in and
eat meatballs
or whatever and i get it
yeah i get it you got to be responsible
but it adds money it adds whatever but
you got to do it
i want to invite here's what i want to
do
with the friendsgiving go with me on
this
here's what i want this is i want to
want this guest list ready
nelk barry weiss
she likes the show i want barry barry
weiss
right the the nell kids that blow up
cars and stuff
barry weiss ryan phillippe fan of the
show
90s heartthrob early 2000s heartthrob
fan of the show
jeff garland fan of the show yes have
him there
okay now we need diversity we talked
about this we can't and i you know
what if we flew in candace owens
to come to the friendsgiving
i i want to reach out to your manager go
i will pay candace owens
ten thousand dollars i will thank
your thank you patrons this is where
your money's going
i will fly candace owens
and and have candace owens and nalc
recreate the george floyd incident
yes or yes
yes and barry weiss
write an article and say that it's okay
i this is the friendsgiving that i would
like
i'm asking if this is possible
i'm not saying that i want a friend's
gift my
parties are not for people to get drunk
and have sex and enjoy
each other's company i want an awkward
time where people that don't like each
other and shouldn't like each other
suffer that's why i want to fill the
room
with like controversial people and then
retards
and then literally just see one at like
youtubers and
and and and and conservative pundits
and and far left people and
just just a nightmare
where it's not fun and no one
understands
why they're there and no one understands
why i put them there that's what i want
like the kneel
parties are fun right tits are out full
send everyone's like enjoying themselves
i
can't explain to you how i want my party
to be the opposite of that
i want barry weiss in the kitchen
like arguing with ethan klein about
something
trying to find common ground i don't
know they'll probably find it
but that's what i would like i would
like that
that's what i want cody co and candace
owens
to discuss the appetizers
i want ryan phillippe
to be there and to have a
discussion with i don't know
james baker why can't we can't get him
we know his granddaughter but
that's the type of party i want a
sexless
awkward stilted
anxiety producing strange
hellish pointless
thing that amuses me i just want to be
amused
for a few hours if i spend the money i
just want to be amused
that's all i want so there's all these
hollywood hills parties that are like
super cool
i just want eggplant parmesan
and and and and people discussing the
election
and i want it divided between like
youtubers who don't know that an
election happened
and like every people that have been
canceled i'll get everybody
i will get i
will have
a karaoke party with barry weiss and
crystalia yes or yes
barry weiss crystalia
brian callan candace owens
tim dillon the nelq people
karaoke maybe don jr
at kimberly guilfoyle
just awkward people are paranoid that
they're gonna be canceled if a photo
leaks
right they don't wanna be they're upset
that they're there
that's what i want
if i'm gonna do a friend's giving it's
gonna be i want it to be that
something that gets people going who is
that
who is that
i want i want to look at a corner of the
room
and see steve bannon explaining
the conflict with china to jake paul
like that's what i want to see i want to
see
that i want to
i want to see that happen that's
and then i can leave la i'm like going
to do another year here
but i only want to do a year here if i
could just kind of create
these moments that just amuse me they
don't matter it's not going to matter
who cares no one's going to care they i
just want to be amused
because i think life is a joke because
it is so i just want to
behave in a in a manner
that is like that and i want to throw
events that are like that i just want to
throw events that are like that
you know where people can
people from all walks of life
but but but really the same walk of life
which is narcissism
that's truly what it is all of the
people i mentioned is different as they
are
they're addicted to themselves and
they're addicted to attention
and i think putting them in a room uh
and serving them food that's
much better than they can even
appreciate
the people in la nobody knows any nobody
knows anything about good food
i mean it would be a way it would be a
waste right this is a waste i got i
could serve the cat food and go get
oscar's dish and
pass it around they've gone yeah
um but that's that's the type of event
that i would like to do and i hope we
get there i don't know that we will i'm
going to
try miramira on the wall what is the
best brand
for my balls manscaped manscaped
manscaped it's the great thing it is
great
it is the it is the thing you shave your
dick
your balls your dick your whole pubic
area you shave it
manscaped is really good it's the best
one on the market it's much better than
the norelco body groom which is one of
the only other ones in
in the market manscaped is it it's great
i'm telling you i use it
i give them to other people that work
with me uh
you know that want them and i'm always
happy about it okay
they have a nose and an ear trimmer
provides proprietary skin safe
technology
which helps prevent knicks snags and
tugs and those delicate holes
i'm telling you this bundle includes a
lawnmower 3.0 trimmer
best trimmer on the market for your
balls butt and body
i mean it's great they have all kinds of
stuff they have a great little travel
bag you can put all this stuff in
you know um i i'm telling you i i don't
even have to sell this it actually works
it's
actually great i use it everyone i know
uses it you have to use it this is
something that
you know if you enjoy the podcast you
get 20 off and free shipping with code
tim d
at manscape.com it's 20 off free
shipping with the code timd at
manscape.com
okay so i would just go do that if you
do not have one
this is a great thing to give to
somebody if you do not have one this is
exactly what you should be doing
i'm telling you i'm telling you right
now i would not lie to you and i would
but not about this
it is great 20 off free shipping code
tim d at manscape.com it's great you
don't feel like you're going to
you're going to nick yourself or that's
the big problem with these things you
think you're just
just going to be like you're going to
you know whatever start a big problem
but you don't feel like that you know
and i think that it's very important
that you basically
you know do what i say now
go to mansky.com and and get 20
off with the code tim d that's
manscape.com
20 off tim d one day
why are you why are you laughing why
can't you why can't you
honor my lived experience will you honor
my lived experience yes i will
one day i was a child
and i was eating a breakfast cereal and
i got lots of sugar in it
i forgot which one it was but it was
colorful sugary and it made me feel
like i was a king of the world you know
i was eating that cereal in my house
and uh i was a victim of a brutal home
invasion did you know this
i've never heard of this did i tell you
about this home invasion
there's a brutal home invasion and
i don't know why you're laughing it's
very traumatic for me
now the men came in
the men were they were uh they were
masked
they had masks on and not covered masks
ski masks and they came in and they had
guns
and i was very scared but not
that scared and
they grabbed my mother by the hair and
they put a gun in her mouth
and i and that would have upset me more
but she was being very nasty that
morning
she was being very rude very nasty
and there was something about kind of
seeing that i was still scared
but i was less i was kind of like you
know it's good that everybody gets a
little comeuppance
if you know what i mean you know what i
mean
and then they hit my father with uh with
the butt of the gun in the back of his
head and he fell down
and then they looked at me and i looked
at them
and i was just frozen and they said keep
eating that cereal
they said that's some good [ __ ] i said
thank you and i said are you gonna kill
my parents they said no
no what's wrong with you we're just
robbing the house i'm like well you
might as well
as well get rid of them right they said
no
they left and my parents woke up
you know and we went on about our lives
but i remember sitting there eating that
cereal and having the point at me and
going you keep eating that cereal king
they said you're a king like that's
right
i wanted to recreate that feeling that
great feeling of watching my parents
get attacked while i ate a sugary cereal
so what i do is i go to magicspoon.com
tim dillon because magic spoon
is so healthy it has zero sugar 11 grams
of protein
and only three net carbs in each serving
there are four flavors cocoa
fruity frosted blueberry
it tastes amazing honestly too good to
be true it's keto friendly
gluten free grain free soy free low carb
gmo free
you know i love the fruity flavor it
tastes like fruit loops
so if you go to magicspoon.com tim
dillon to grab a variety pack and try
today
be sure to use promo code tim dillon to
check out to get free shipping
magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed by 100 happiness
guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked but everybody likes it
everybody likes magic spoon we have it
all over the place we eat it
and i like it because it reminds me of
my childhood
and the great memories the great
memories
i remember that my mother was like you
you better do better in school and then
that door
opened up and they just
gun right in her mouth and i just kind
of looked at her like what were you
saying
what were you saying about school
what were you saying about school and my
father comes in
what's going on
right to the ground and i
uh i i appreciate those men because
those men recognized
in me they saw something in me they saw
potential you saw a leader
and they said this guy should just eat a
cereal so they pounded me out they're
like king
it's back where you could pound you'd
have to do that dumb elbow [ __ ] because
it covered
they pounded me out magicspoon.com tim
dillon
are you going to texas for thanksgiving
no no staying here
interesting yeah a lot of people are not
traveling no no a lot of people are not
traveling for the holidays
we might go to new york in december yeah
they're shutting it all down but new
york's now got the national guard out
cuomo's got the guard
meatball has the guard out in the
airports now
how about you get the national guard to
surround your brother's house because
she's a liar
liar liar pants on fire
i mean i i i'm kind i really fed up with
new york i'd love to go back
um but i just don't know i think covet
covert is just gonna
the winter is shot the winter was shot
we've rescheduled the dates in denver
and omaha
kansas city i've explained why
a lot of these clubs are cutting
capacity
this time the other thing on the other
end of this and then a lot of them
are like well we're not canceled yet but
we we are hearing things that we maybe
can i'm like i just wanna
let's just put it three months in the
future where
we can do it and we could do it in a
capacity hopefully
that is back to so we just got to get
over this second whatever it is
second wave second hump
and then we can go back out make people
laugh live because that's what we want
to do but
but until then we are podcasting here
we're podcasting on patreon
and that's what we're doing we're we're
not we're you know we're just trying to
live
we're trying to go out to dinner we're
trying to
you know connect with friends with
people we don't like but we have to
see when you when you're in your 30s
your friends are just people you know
they're not even people you like really
they're just
people you've met
that's true they're people you've met
because it's
oma in your 30s i'm 35. what starts to
happen is
you start to have this realization that
you're like
you know the golden moments of
friendship when you're like
you're like young and you're like we're
gonna we're gonna take over the world
and
we're gonna go to college and uh bang so
many [ __ ] or whatever and then you
find out that you're gay and you're not
going to college
and your parents have no money and
they're degenerates
and then and then it's all over with the
friend what are your friendships what do
we do with the friendships
and then the only friends you have are
people that come up to you and go i
think you're so talented and then you
find out that they're living in a pool
of blood
so what you know
so that so you know i have a small group
we got a small group of friends i got a
small group of friends
ben this frat kid dan
who's smarter than most frat kids barry
weiss
ryan phil i i've never met barry i've
never even met barry white supposedly
she's a fan of the show i don't even
know what that meant
i don't even know what that means she
looks like a
pastry you know what i mean
she says very incendiary things but
she's got a very doughy
face that you imagine like gives you
some type of
baked good
supposedly she want to have lunch with
me i love lunch whether i don't care
sure
should i should i do a video as barry
wise
she's on the view now oh yeah barry
weiss is on the view
man the view just won't die huh the
views been around forever
yeah i can't play any clips but yeah
yeah she's on the view don't play any
clips look at our girl megan did megan
have the baby yet
i think so and barry weiss and megan
mccain
these guys sawing their [ __ ] off
yeah she gave birth good for her
good for her i mean the [ __ ] blocked me
what did i do i had a little minute of
fun at your expense
and you got angry at me for no
reason i did nothing wrong
she looks good yeah she does good for
her she looks
good
is that is that where he bought her
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm kidding folks what is that a farm
i guess it's her ranch or something
godly hey god love them
i wish them the best i wish them the
best
any news on the election before we get
out of here oh let's see
what if trump pulls it out i would laugh
let me tell you now
if trump pulls it out i would laugh so
hard look at these two goons
look at these two i mean could the
rotting corpse of america
have a better representation than these
two goofs
trump was a pretty good one but these
two are just as good
joe biden and kamala biden harris
it just sounds like a [ __ ] scam
biden harris it's like
you know it's not gonna be much better
right
he's gonna make it a year a year and a
half then she's in
and she'll do the uh she'll do the eight
she'll do the
no one's gonna beat her in 2024 maybe
they will i don't know
i don't know how do you how do you
follow trump
you talk about an act to follow it's
tough to follow trump right
really hard to follow him
but what we will see is we will see i
think a little political idealism
you know you ever see the candle thing
you know you're not catholic but the
little candle thing that snuffs out the
candle yes yes yes
that's what we're seeing here that there
it is that's the candle number
and the light of idealism is gonna go
away
a little bit because of uh you know
the corporate dems are back daddy
daddy's back
mommy and daddy are back and you can
tweet and you can tap dance
and you can make a collage and you could
go on reddit
and you could go on every side
imaginable
the ones that no one even hosts you can
you can
go anywhere and you could do you could
you could any
hey any diatribe you like anything you
like
at the end of the day the corporate
power is back
and you know
that's it there's gonna be a lot of
young kids a lot of maga hats
being taken off a lot of people are
gonna go
now and they're gonna they're gonna this
is how the zoomers become the boomers
boomers at one time had idealism they
were on acid
but they had idealism and then it gets
beaten out the system
beats it out of you you see
and then you become a drone and you just
that's why i i say escape if you can
the system and do not live
where this is real you live in another
place where you're like oh my friends
are real
my family's real the things i'm doing
around oh this isn't real i don't
participate in this
that way you never get too high you
never get too low you're never like the
revolution's coming
and then you're also never like
because neither one of them is happening
the revolution's not happening
right and and also like you know
whatever type of fascism that
comes to this country and it will come
it'll come with like a doughnut you'll
get a donut
you'll get to take it off the gun the
gun will come in your door you take the
donut off the gun
so
i don't want to be too negative here
folks and i and i hope i'm not
i i do believe that's why i have i
i i pick good people to be in my life i
pick
positive people you know
and uh and i pick interesting people and
if you can do that if you pick
interesting people to be in your life
you pick positive people to be in your
life
um then you yourself will
not be bored at the very least right
we have a lot of cool stuff coming up
new
things we're going to debut on youtube
new sketches we just did a sketch
did very well uh it was taken off
youtube briefly we had to fight to get
it back on
yeah hey man 20 20. yes a [ __ ]
um but we've got a lot of new stuff
coming up
um just keep the and this is i i didn't
want to
i'm not trying to assault this waitress
by the way
what i'm trying to say respectfully to
shut your mouth
because we all have as the great elaine
stritch said about her husband who used
to say this
we all have a bag of rocks everybody's
got a bag of rocks you know
we don't need that at dinner you don't
need to come in
and tell me how bad things are
i know how bad things are we're sitting
in a parking lot
uh with traffic cones eating french
onion soup
i know how bad it is they're taking
this beautiful old french restaurant
historic and demolishing it
so that some [ __ ] [ __ ] can live in a
high rise in
an echo park an area that should just be
firebombed i know how bad it is
i'm trying to escape that with salt fat
sugar and carbohydrates stay out of my
way
that's all stay out of my way emily
respect i know it's a tough job i know
it's a tough job
they're the heroes the servers they're
the heroes
and i'm hoping to god that we could pull
off this party and it could be a fun
event we could do some really memorable
things i don't know if that'll happen or
not but i'm just saying this i'm saying
that i think now that people heard this
they're like well i'm not coming now
[ __ ] [ __ ]
do we do we offer candice someone's
money to fly in
yeah i think so maybe we just maybe we
just fly our first class
is can we do that we probably have to
offer a little bit of money
okay put her up in a hotel
okay dude what if we do this and i'm not
even kidding
i'm not even kidding i think let me just
think about this for a minute
what if we throw this like hollywood
friendsgiving [ __ ]
and when people walk in it's a
candace owens like count the votes thing
where she's getting all these people
to like donate their money to for
recounts
across america and oh and and we just
have
and i'm just doing it like a big
instagram story that's like look who's
here to support
the recount effort poor ryan phillip
he's like dude what the [ __ ]
i'm like right philippe look it's jeff
garland here to support the recount
with candace owens
i mean i think it would be fun
timdillycomedy.com go there if you want
there's nothing there who cares
[Laughter]
waste your time nobody's been to a
website since 1986.
uh we have merch life in the big city
shirts
megan mccain hoodies we got new merch
coming out in december we have
we have a really cool yes or yes thing
that's coming out we've got some other
things too
we do appreciate everybody's support on
patreon we've done a lot of cool
episodes of jre
uh in the past couple of
weeks right it's like three three three
in a month yeah
crazy crazy i remember the first time i
did that show and now i've done it like
seven times crazy yeah
the alex episode's massive and that
election thing was really good too
um so there's some of the merch get the
pullover
hoodie for 37.99 you could get the
unisex t for 24.99 it's fun it's like a
fun
it's fun merch get the daddy mug if you
like
yeah i love daddy hoodie we also have a
pink one right
yeah you can change the colors yeah
unless they stopped offering pink i
wonder if maybe they stopped offering
pink
it does look better with the darker
color it does
but we have more stuff coming out in
december don't
fret don't worry about it we're gonna do
some interactive stuff too because we
want it we want to hear from the people
we want to figure out what to do with
the people
we've got live events coming up
rescheduled shows
hoping this [ __ ] covet thing
just gets to you know
hoping that we have a nice peaceful
transition to power
what's the most gangster way for trump
to go out
killing himself in the oval office like
bud dwyer like calling a press
conference i'm wondering like what's the
biggest
what i mean he's a he's a master of
ratings what's the series finale
uh maybe he could disappear like just
get on a plane and just leave and then
just
just disappear just goes radio silent no
one even knows where he is wow
because that's very unlike him yeah
wow i'm wondering like how does the the
gang how does he go out how does a guy
go out how does this guy go out
you know dude if he finds a way to win
i'm going to tell you right now if he
finds a way to if they recount these
votes and somehow he won
it will be the funniest
it will be the funniest thing
oh we're recording this friday night by
the way friday yeah yeah
so it's changing with with every hour so
that's why ben's here to do the
technical yeah why
what if he just appointed himself to
like the supreme court or something
i'm trying to think what he could do
what could he really do
i don't know i'm really trying to rack
my brain
like what could this guy do
him by dwiring himself i mean that would
be like the most
historic moment like ever if he did that
just envelope
gun out crazy right just i was
you know it was rigged i was framed or
whatever and
i'll be the craziest thing i don't see
him doing that but that would be the
craziest thing
maybe he himself could become a
terrorist like maybe he flies like air
force one
into like the the world trade center or
something like that like the freedom
tower
you trying to get us banned from
everything with these suggestions
trying to get us banned off every
service i mean
what would it maybe maybe he could be
coming
to a flyer for his wanting to enter into
an orphanage
you keep that to yourself that's why we
don't have you do all the talking
fly air force one into where did you say
the freedom tower
you want donald trump to fly air force
one into the freedom town yeah yeah
i got to be honest not the worst
not the worst idea can you imagine being
at lunch somewhere and going what's on
the news
why is everyone in the break room donald
trump just flew
air force one into the freedom tower
and survived what if he survived somehow
i wonder if he's considering that like
he's sitting there with his people
and they're like he's like well we got
the recount and we're suing georgia
got the recount in pennsylvania he's
like what if he goes let me just throw
something else out there while we're all
talking
it's like while we're all spitballing
why don't i fly air force one into the
freedom tower
they're like well there's no precedent
for that
but we don't know
perhaps there's something well folks
listen
we don't have a president you know we
barely have a country
yeah you know but we have merch
understand we have dreams and hopes
so do you
i hope that waitress tonight this is
what i hope happens
i hope she goes home she realizes how
good she has it
how lucky she is to be in the fight
how absolutely lucky she is
and i hope she's jubilant and happy
i hope she goes downstairs because she
wants to get some air
you know and i hope she's shot in the
head
so that nobody will ever have to listen
to that depressing horseshit while
they're trying to eat a meal again
good night